good to see you again from vegas at the
latin grammys to la here for jingle ball
okay now i know you're go sweetie's
performing so is it safe to assume
you're gonna hit that stage today
i mean i will hit the stage but not with
her because we had different spots okay
but
i'm really happy to be at the same
place and same stage as sweetie she's so
nice and uh for me it's not only that
it's so many amazing people and i've
been just like my career in english just
started this year so for me it's kind of
crazy to be already here with so many
amazing big artists you know and also
not to be outdone there's global artists
here there's you there's bts like it's
kind of amazing it's amazing yeah i mean
and coming from brazil and then
latin grammy and mixing these so many
cultures
portuguese spanish english is crazy my
mind sometimes like girls
you're living your dream do you look
around and just like pinch yourself yeah
no because it's hard because you're busy
working
you know why because for me it's like
i'm starting over like starting again
like her
come here sweetie
making love team fakie love team
what's up girl come on in here
i was hoping for a performance of fakie
love today i mean i'm gonna sing but i'm
gonna watch my girl hey listen i'm my
best friend i love it because
it's
not my best friend she's a real bad man
her own car she don't need no lips and a
strip club by the way that was nominated
for it
congratulations on that grammy
nomination by the way with best friend
are you pinching yourself and best new
artist come on thank you i know that's
right
hey it's icy season baby thank you you
look amazing i love you
good matching you're amazing yeah yeah
for sure all right i'm down
do it called in sick you guys got time
yeah you do it do it do it oh i love her
i love her she is
the funniest and the coolest is just so
good um what was it like collaborating
with her and what's something we'd be
surprised to know about her uh
i mean i think everybody knows she loves
food
she knows a lot about it it's not it's
not
news to anyone i think but in the music
video she was always eating something
interesting
we're okay so she likes to eat we love
that no and she cooks really well oh you
know what i saw that on that cooking
with paris shows she was really good
she's making those sweetie tacos yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah um okay so talk to
me about the holiday season don't you
feel like we're just living in mariah
carey's fantasy every christmas uh i
mean i'm a suspect to talk about it
because i'm the number one mariah
carey's fan
so i mean for me i'm always about mariah
all the year not only during fresno yep
yep you know but uh definitely yes she
brings this special moment
and i think there's not even such for me
only christmas is such a special my
favorite moment of the year
could represent mariah because she is as
special as christmas so for me it's the
best thing so now that you're working on
your english records have you thought
about maybe putting in an ask asking
your girl mariah to collab with you
obviously who knows what happened okay
all right okay
did you already ask ah
i don't know yeah okay
that would be a dream come true right
yeah yeah yeah definitely last question
for you have you been naughty or nice
this year
uh have i been i've been um
i've been nice okay there you go i'm a
very nice girl of course you are looking
she's got the lips she's a nice i'm
ready to kiss everyone who crossed my
way that's right exactly where's the
mistletoe we need a mistletoe for anita
stat
i'm just ready just come on away
come cross my way i'm ready
[Music]